[Music]
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings bae don't be
afraid don't be ashamed don't hesitate
to say hey babe
maybe she's born with it maybe it's hey
babe what's up babe what's up babe what
are you doing good i feel good yeah
everything's good man you look good look
healthy thank you man you too dude and
you know what i like about you is you
got w's on your sweatshirt and all
actually it says g there's all different
letters g h oh g raw you know what this
is about i had to spend my my gift card
that's the gift card shirt this this was
on the show once before i think now
we're back in fall weather i'm back to
my sweatshirts babes is there anything
better
than fall weather seriously that's
what's better than weather but it's a
yeah nothing because i said with the new
york accent is there anything better
than fall weather
that's what it is yeah yeah because it's
not about pumpkins for me it's not about
spices cold i think
we should see do a poll and see what
people like the best because fall is the
dopest [ __ ] the weather fall may have a
slight chill in the air and that's one
of the best things about it sure beaches
in the summer and skiing in winter are
fine and good but nothing beats a hike
outside in the fall as you gawk
like a hawk at the absolute beauty of
red white and blue oh no red golden
orange yeah no fall is great because
it's like you know it's a sweatshirt
like jacket whether it's a nip in the
air but it's oh yeah everyone everyone
welcomes the fall it ushers in the
seasons the mood holidays here's why the
fall is good for me number one i've told
you i like i like crisp i like crispness
i'm a 55 to 60 degree guy with a little
clausius i love that
i love not having allergies my allergies
go bye bye bye bye
when fall comes around i don't get any
allergies at all and i like you know
when you do get allergies
when it's gonna be maybe
nice dude see that very nice by the way
i noticed on um
taste buds the other day a couple
episodes ago that you guys did
backstreet boys
versus
new kids on the board in synchronous new
kids that's the joe de rosa first new
kids but why would you not do backstreet
boys versus in sync
who who's like was that deroses
because backstreet boys versus insane
would have been the ultimate battle
that's i can't i mean it would have been
50 50. i know i know
i know and i actually really want to
know the winner of that
yeah i know but he thought and i get his
thinking but it's always easier in
hindsight to be like whatever but his
thinking was new kids on the block were
the first
no like they were the they were the the
og's word to the wise never go with joe
derose's thinking yeah that's not a good
thing the next episode i'd like you guys
to do is north first south
ooh
north
what year
i'm kidding um the fall you know what's
interesting is i don't even like i don't
even like leaving
the north eastern area during the fall i
will leave to go to durham on october
29th with you to co-headline a great
show where we do 30 to 40 minutes of
stand up each and then we do a little
mini hey babe and people wear costumes
that's nove october 29th costumes deepak
i will do that at the d-pack deepak
chopra durham performing arts center
i will do that yes but i don't even like
i don't like like for me like if i see a
gig on my list where i'm like i got to
go to like a florida or i got to go to
the west coast in october november
december
i don't i don't want to fungus
[Laughter]
no i don't want to go no i love those
states yeah independently but i during
the during the fall yeah because one
thing i love about the fall foliage is
being in the massachusetts new england
area
everybody talks about anything better
everyone talks about new england clam
chowder i want to talk about new england
foliage you know there's traffic on the
highways now just for foliage just
because people want to look at the
leaves while they're driving i shoot up
to the hudson area yeah i go up there
like you know or whatever go up to
beacon or rhinebeck or like a socrates
or something like that uh every fall i
go stay for the weekend i go look at the
foliage where do you go
those places i just mentioned oh you
just and you just find a hotel a
woodstock yeah there's really nice
places up there when are you going this
year are you gonna go uh yeah yeah i
actually went once already you went once
ready just to stay but it was in the
fall i went for the for the day
on my way up i had to show an oneonta
and i went on the way
yeah but no it wasn't quite full just
yet oh man it's the best to go i want to
go there's some good restaurants up
there
take a stroll down a day go to the park
a little bike ride yeah it's dude it's
it's un it really unplugs
you unplugged there i know there's a
place like mohawk mountain you ever
heard of that you know new york mohawk
it's like a it's like a this nice place
mohank hunk i think but yeah just
literally if you upstate new york or the
new england area if you're not from here
if you're but you live in the
continental united states do yourself a
favor during the fall months come to the
northeast i think it probably is the
best place to be during the fall right
where's better to be there
all right next week january 14th and
15th i will be in austin texas at the
big vulcan gas company austin texas it's
going to be so much fun then january
21st orlando florida co-headlining with
andrew dice clay january 22nd tampa
florida at the tampa theater january
29th atlantic city new jersey february
5th i will be at the beacon theater and
then february 11th and 12th washington
dc and atlanta georgia and then in march
we have detroit we have cleveland we got
the chicago theater march 12th seattle
portland in march vegas in march we got
a bunch of them but the ones coming up
january 1415 austin texas january 21st
22nd we have got co-headlining with
andrew dice clay at the hard rock in
orlando and the tampa theater in tampa
so i'm really excited go to
chrisdcomedy.com for tickets what's up
everybody uh we've been locked up for a
long time and now i'm finally getting on
the road again so i hope to see you uh
and then i will be on tour solo in des
moines indianapolis cleveland san diego
la burlington a second show added at
foxwoods detroit pittsburgh albany
washington dc which is really tyson's
virginia madison wisconsin and chicago
uh all in jan in february all of those
are on sale right this second at
savillcanocomedy.com
can't wait to see you guys god bless um
by the way i had apples what what i back
now are apple cider donuts apple cider
donuts i think is the best donut it's a
seasonal donut so you don't really get
used to it like the chocolate donuts
amazing but the apple cider donut it's
so light when you go when you go apple
picking or pumpkin picking can you get
an apple cider donut or any type of
sweets
from like a farm a pumpkin picking farm
it's the best
thing that you can ever do even roadside
roadside stand eat it you'll eat an
apple cider donut oh my goodness yeah my
god you know superman's gay yeah
his son is bi
we talked about yeah how about this
gavin newsom
uh for 2021 gavin newsom the uh the
governor of california of california as
a much talked about california law
requiring large retailers to provide
gender-neutral toy selections but in my
opinion like most toys are
gender-neutralized unless it's a bit
unless it's a boy or a girl
anything that's not a boy or a girl i
don't know the gender like but i'm
saying i've never i guess no because
they were showing a stuffed uh all my
kids no man i guess because that's the
thing is all my kids toys snow woman
has anyone ever made a snow woman does
anyone
no
i mean do we have to make a snow why is
that but why why is there not a snow
woman
there should be a snow woman because if
anything
because a snowman's body is voluptuous
like a woman yeah
look at that but but these are i guess
people decided to make snow women but
it's not in like the there's no snow
woman in any type of christmas tale yeah
like we've had jack first what about
jill frost yeah
i want jill frost how did it even oh i
guess they don't need to procreate they
just they get built out of snow but my
point is is any toy my kids ever brought
home
they've never had a penis and balls or a
vagina there's never a space there for
the genitals yeah like yeah it could be
have a dress on and cinderella but
cinderella doesn't have a vagina when i
have to take her clothes off to put her
clothes on another dog and my daughter
yells at me because i can't get the
clothes off and i'm like my fingers
aren't small i'm not ratatouille right
i'm a grown man trying to take a
doll-sized clothes off this [ __ ] doll
right hold your horses
you don't even need your lunch i know
just tell it sometimes you just use the
f i gotta tell her just say shut the
[ __ ] up
yeah she's not funny she thinks you're
out of tui she thinks i'm rounded to me
but i know every time we see him out we
would see mouse and our mice in our old
department like all ratatouille i tried
to make it cute and fun but we'd have a
wild vermin problem
she's like great we'll have porridge
later yes um
so that's that's the thing with gender
neutral toys is is they've never had
genders to begin with so i don't i don't
agree with you or would it be a
gender-neutral toy would be an example
um like a gender-neutral toy would be
like oh not a general neutr a gender
neutral
figure more of a gender-neutral
playset of any kind right is that what
you mean
yeah but did they say like
gender-neutral like you don't like uh a
figurine that doesn't identify as as
male or female which one was that i
don't know what gavin i don't to be
honest with you i never really know what
the hell california's talking about or
doing i don't know what you're even
saying that you're mandating
gender-neutral toys gavin i just don't
know what you mean yeah i don't know
all um
all different ethnicities in the dolls
and stuff like that and to make sure you
get your kids all different like you
know what yeah that's all that's
ethnicities and stuff but i i still
don't know what it means uh to have a
gender like yeah like a playset that
could be for a boy or a girl i guess but
i mean my kids you know i got i got a
boy and two girls they're all playing
with each other's stuff all day every
day yeah i don't even think you develop
a gender until you're about 15.
i think i don't think i don't think
anybody has a gender really it doesn't
develop until you're about 15. yeah
that's what i'll say here on hay baby
that's who we said that before you know
what this has been hey baby
um okay most children tip okay they
typically develop the ability to
recognize and label stereotypical gender
groups such as girl woman and feminine
boy man and masculine teenagers 18 and
24 months interesting most categories
their own gender by age three there you
go so yeah when your kid's about three
years old they'll start to uh they'll
start to know so how's your new baby
doing with their gender so far my baby's
four months old my baby's four months
old right now i would say
does she know she's a boy or a girl yet
i don't think so she has just been
discovering her hands she has been she
like looks at her hands now like you'll
ask her a question you'll be like hey
baby like what do you want to eat she
just go like that she'll just look at
her hand and then she'll go like that
she'll squeeze her fists up she'll just
squeeze her fist every time you wake up
she's just looking at you squeezing her
fist which is good
yesterday
literally
i mean literally
like it was
a game like a movie i picked her up to
move her
from her like little play mamaroo thing
we have into the high chair because
we're all going to eat so she just sits
with us even though she can't eat i mean
she doesn't even know what
her face is right she just gets milk
when we give it to her but she just sits
in the high chair with us while we're
eating dinner and she just look at us
like what are you idiots doing give me
my bottle but we were sitting there
we were sitting there um and as i was
taking her from the the little mama who
thing to the to the high chair i went to
go give her a kiss like open my kitchen
say i love you and she vomited like a
full vomit like a water fountain
directly into my mouth and because i was
in such a panic i swallowed something oh
it was crazy
oh yeah i [ __ ] out of rattle this
morning
what did that taste like it was nasty it
doesn't taste like your own throb does
it no because it's like a milk it's not
a formula no i love my kid more than
anything but to just drink and no that's
somebody else's vomit
she's lucky you didn't projectile back
at her as a natural reflex i almost did
she drinks your vomit and just keeps
going back and forth like a like a like
a family guy sketch i almost and you
know what we had yesterday we had
gnocchi we had some gnocchi yeah and as
a joke i told my 10 year old stepson i
was oh 11 year old step so now i mean it
doesn't matter you i feel like if the
stepson you can get the ballpark age six
months
six months 10 to 14 years old you know
yeah i love him but he's not he's my
stepson so i don't know the exact
numbers here
it's like how they do the consensus uh
the census yeah bureau like he's between
the ages of 25 and 34. yeah yeah yeah so
so um so i said to him you know because
he's not that big of an ear i was just
joking around i mean i think because the
gnocchi looked like caterpillars i was
like oh look mom made his caterpillars
and sauce everyone said thanks to my
vegas catapult sauce and he goes i'm not
eating that
and i said i'm kidding around
i cut it up and i said it's cheese and
it goes no no i'm no i'm not gonna eat
it so what happens he sat there he sat
there and didn't eat and then everyone
was eating and he was like you guys are
just gonna eat caterpillar like that
real nice cause he's 11 years old but
he's very animal against animal cruelty
he's a like vegetarian full vegetarian
so he does not eat meat he does not eat
meat at all he will need anything he's a
vegetarian he's a full vegetarian on his
own accord uh well his dad is very much
against animal oh you know about animals
so they nobody eats meat even jasmine
doesn't mean no but the only people that
eat meat in are me and my daughters oh
well me and my daughter i'm assuming
when my four month old she'll probably
meet but we meet and they look at us
like we are full nazis wow they're like
i can't believe you're doing that you
know so he wouldn't eat it he was like
i'm not gonna eat so does he get didn't
have to make something did make him
something else yeah
yeah well no i mean i don't know what
you know i we i just ate his portion
because i was like i just ate more
gnocchi
and um and and no but i was like i was
like wow like just making a little joke
like that because if you literally
say anything like like for me like if
you said to me like i could be
ravishingly hungry yeah and if you if
you said while i'm eating the food if
you started eating my food if you
started talking about anything gross
like you know like i don't know like
skinning my kneecaps or something like
that i would not be able to eat like my
my stomach just shuts off yeah you too
uh if i see something like if i'm
watching television or something like
that why isn't that a diet then why does
everyone pour money into jenny craig
yeah when you get hungry just turn on dr
pimple popper yeah why not that that's
your dog you'll be waiting you'll be
kate moss you need to lose 20 pounds
yeah then why don't you sit down with
your tv dinner put on dr pimple
and have a kernel of corn and get the
hell out of here and go vomit yeah
that's what i'm saying
how it works like us even mentioning dr
uh pimplepopper do you does it bother
you with the salad no impact no impact
him can eat or anything yeah i don't
care i don't care but you're pretty
reckless i saw you buy a tuna fish
sandwich at a truck stop that was crazy
did i eat it
uh you paid 11 oh yeah that's right yeah
no
you can't do that i know i was we were
hungry and we couldn't eat
pimp pimp eats a lot of string cheese he
eats too much drink cheese oh it's it's
hard to not every i don't know
they come in those things like eight and
you just rip them off each other and i
tell you i had to like when i have
string cheese in the in the drawer in
the fridge it's always on my mind really
i'm like because it's at any moment i
could have string cheese i'm the kind of
guy and i think i've i must have
mentioned this before on the podcast
it's a big part of me if you know me you
know this is true i can't eat cold
cheese i've told you that oh i thought
you couldn't eat melted cheese no melted
cheese is all i can eat oh i messed that
up i actually recently told someone that
you can't eat melted cheese well
it's just it says a lot about our
friendship yeah i messed that up no me
at all you're not paying attention
you're not trying to make a difference
you
imagine i threw the microphone right off
the balcony and i left
you get paid to train hispanics on the
pommel horse
that's what i do
i literally this jacket first of all
i wasn't gonna bring it up but it's it's
it's suits you so well for some reason
that i like i just wanted to call that
you you you know how we were talking
about how you couldn't pull off pimp's
outfit if you walked down the street
yeah last episode was that last episode
yeah yeah and uh and and i was like
you'd fail
you could walk down the street in the
south and i believe it i would believe
it in this puerto rico outfit yeah dude
this literally came in the mail to my
house and obviously my whole entire
family is puerto rican besides me right
and i just was like i literally opened
it was like this must be for me and then
i put it on and like no one's ever
claimed it but there's no but like
literally i have a house full of puerto
ricans i get a jacket says puerto rico
and i'm like this is mine
like and i've worn it now out multiple
times that's this is a double xl by the
way and it fits a little tight so i need
to stop eating caterpillars
hey babes listen we know that if you are
like two out of three men
in this country in the world you're
probably suffering from male pattern
baldness okay
it happens what can you do you've had
some type of hair loss by the time
you're 35 more than 50 million men in
the united states suffer from male
pattern baldness and there's only two
fda approved medications that prevent
hair loss and guess who offers them both
keeps baby k-e-e-p-s
keeps your hair you bald [ __ ]
listen if you're ready to take action
and prevent hair loss go to keeps
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash hey babe to
receive your first month of treatment
for free
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash hey babe
to get your first month for free keeps
has more five-star reviews in its
competitors low cost treatment start at
just ten dollars a month it's got a
convenient virtual doctor consultation
and medications delivered straight to
your door or for
every three months and you don't have to
leave your home okay so it's perfect
k-e-e-p-s dot com
hey babe don't put it on your pubes
listen a lot of people are making new
year's resolutions and i get it and a
lot of people like to exercise and lose
weight and you know the best way to do
that is with music and the only way that
i exercise or go for walks or hikes the
only thing i put in my ear is raycon
earbuds baby ray khan wireless earbuds i
love them i love anything ray j does and
he's the owner of this company um
there's all there's this they have this
new thing it's called awareness mode for
when you need to listen to your
surroundings you can take the raycons
with you wherever you go so it's really
like you're not going to get hit by a
car or you could just hear things you
know i can hear vinnie yelling at me in
the background all that stuff raycon
earbuds i'm telling you they never fall
out of your ears never and i have very
very weird ear shapes doctors have told
me like you may need an ear surgery
because your ears just they look [ __ ]
up and raycons never ever fall out of my
weird shaped ears um
and they also you do that shake test you
know like when you when you shake them
and they never fall out and i'm always
shaking my head i used to have to wear a
helmet when i was a kid and and
they never fall out it's no wonder ray
guns everyday earbuds have over 48 000
five-star reviews they got offer eight
hours of play time and a 32-hour battery
life that's more hours than in a day
except if you're on saturn um right now
listeners can get 15 percent off their
raycon order at by buy raycon
r-a-y-c-o-n
dot com slash hey babe that's by raycon
dot com slash hey babe say fifty percent
on ray cons by raycon dot com slash hey
babe
puerto rican and listen seven years now
with a puerto rican woman i've been i'm
in graciated with the puerto ricans yeah
yeah you know
i'm a puerto rican freaking you know i'm
a freaking puerto rican it's a freaking
puerto rican yeah have you guys ever
been thrown out of the zoo thrown out of
the zoo
thrown out
yeah because you reminded me with the
string cheese i've been thrown at the
zoo a lot why'd you get thrown in why
would you be doing a zoo a lot my dad's
an old school guy and he just expects
that he's able to feed the animals at
the zoo
yeah cheese and cheese
when's the time even been to this i love
feeding an animal even when it says
doesn't
i do i i follow the rules but in my life
have i ever thrown a kernel somewhere
and be like don't say nothing like i've
done it because you almost feel like i
get it it [ __ ] up the ecosystem or
something like that all right or they
you don't want to feed them stuff they
can't have because they're dietary
restrictions you don't want to mess with
this eating schedule a lot of good
reasons well yeah because sometimes
nowadays i mean who knows what these
animals are they keto are they
vegetarian you have no idea i don't know
you don't know if they're gluten if
they're not seriously you're going to
notice you know you go nihina dead or
something like that i don't know but i
don't know i don't know what's going on
yeah
you know what my story about the zoo and
i stopped me if i told this on hey baby
did i tell you about my aunt and uncle
met like full met and had my cousin did
i tell you the story i believe so this
was a hey babe story i think where the
monkey took it [ __ ] in its hand and hit
my uncle in the face yeah and my aunt
wiped it off and then he got infection
in his eye pink eye and all that stuff i
don't remember all the deets
okay oh well then
then go back go back to one of the
episodes and he got [ __ ] and then that's
how they met well they met because she
was wiping the crap off his face yeah
and then some of it got in his eye and
he got like ravishing i mean when you
get monkey crap in your eyes that's a
that's a special pink eye yeah yeah yeah
you can't go to the local rite aid cvs
dwayne reed and guys that's a hot pink
guy that's a hot pink eye nice yeah so
that is so but that's how they met
that's how they met and then eventually
had my cousin and you know were married
for a few years yeah got divorced and
now he's dead
r.i.p
not from the pink eye though okay you
have the full life okay okay yeah but he
just died of natural shout out full
lives natural cause shout out for life
natural cause i'm always i'm always
taken aback when i see someone die
at like 30 and the cause says natural
causes i'm like that's a bad that
happens is that a thing yeah sometimes
you'll see somebody dies of necessarily
natural causes just like failure because
everything is kind of expired when i
think your body the i think natural
cause is when the the the the coroner
opens up but your body is just so [ __ ]
that it's just like it has to be natural
causes yeah i mean in simple terms
natural causes refer to internal factors
like a medical condition or a disease
as opposed to external factors like
trauma from an accident
ah okay so natural causes is anything
that's not getting hit by a truck so if
you got cancer you died of natural
causes no no that's feeling that's
exactly word
no but it's that disease
disease
interesting oh so that doesn't i've
never realized that natural causes
anything that's that's biological maybe
a coroner a coroner's job in this day
and age is tough because let's say you
have coven you get hit by a bus
you're dead
but
but
because it's very easy to say oh well
the bus killed you you died of you had
you got hit by the bus right but what
happens if your lungs could have
survived
and breathe through it had you not had
covet what killed you what came first
right the chicken or the egg right the
covert of the bus that's why i'm glad
i'm not a what are they called
more uh mortician more tissue no that's
not who's
down at the corner that's why i'm glad
what would you give it to if you had to
if you had to guess you want to tweet
that poll out if you get by you buy bus
with covert what do you do
is the coin on me right are you checking
clovid or boss yeah that was that's
that's a big that's not really a hot
topic right now no no i understand it's
a hot topic but i'm just if you really
think about it i don't know what i do i
would probably die you die bus if the
coroner honestly if i was stuck if it
was like a mid-size or a compact car i
would maybe give it to the kobet govind
yeah i honestly at that point just
because i'd be so flustered i wouldn't
go either or i would just say
non-hodgkin's lymphoma right that's what
i'd say i just call it natural i'd say
no i i just i'd make something else
completely up it's a you know what
the truth of the situation he had none
oh if you were a coroner if i was a car
and i'd just make up another thing
i mean i mean you got to be like did you
do you know do you know a coroner do you
know someone who knows a corner i don't
know a corner but i did go to high
school with a person who owned a uh a
funeral home after he got into that
business yeah i know someone owned a
funeral home i know more i knew a
mortician hey babe email heybaypod
gmail.com or tweet us at haybaypod and
let us know if you're a coroner cause
what do you do to get into that business
there listen how do you not take that
with you in your subconscious section i
know disrespect because i know we need
that profession but you have to have
somewhat of a screw-ish
screw loose-ish yeah to do that no again
i know that maybe it was like an emo kid
yeah yeah
something had to go
something had to go a rye bread in your
in your childhood
i mean we need there are champions there
without yeah like how would we solve
anything i couldn't be one
no i couldn't be one i guess you have to
have you have to have that thing in your
brain where that stuff does not register
it doesn't affect you or no you have to
disassociate obviously disassociated
wonder if it's as easy as that though i
wonder there's a coroner who's been the
coroner for like 20 years and it's like
i thought it was gonna be like i could
disassociate but i can't but i can't
yeah but now i have to stay yeah well
yeah see that's the thing yeah i don't
know and it's interesting if like i'm
surprised there's no corn or podcast
that'd be interesting oh they're cutting
up a body they're doing a part about it
did they cut them up is there there's an
automatic i think that's what the corner
did the
a coroner is an elected official what
what i'd never seen that i'm bill
jenkins and i'm running for california
coroner
do you want your organs misplaced and
rearranged in your body
in some stupid way then you can vote
democrat um investigations of deaths
occurring with the specific autopsies
slip and
falls diseases if you're carrying a
credit card balance monday after month
it can feel like you're in a
never-ending cycle of debt with no end
in sight upstart can help you make that
final payment so you can get ahead
rather than looking at credit score
alone upstart considers other factors
like your income current employment and
credit history to find you to find you a
smarter rate for your loan so right now
if you want to get a loan pimpy if you
want to get a loan
all you got to do and by the way a loan
between 1 000 and 50 000 all you gotta
do is to find out how is go to upstart
they can lower your payments today when
you go to upstart.com
hey babe that's upstart.com
hey babe do not forget to use our url to
let them know we sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application
upstart.com
hey babe
do you know what i love when i hear that
i love that and when i hear that on
shopify it makes me horny genuinely
horny i have to call a doctor about it
keep getting erection every time i go on
the shopify site it's awesome okay
shopify gives entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big business
so hey baby so upstart startups and
established businesses alike can sell
everywhere synchronize online and
in-person sales and effortlessly stay
informed
listen it's more than a store shop fight
it grows with you it's the possibili
this is the possibility powered by
shopify gain insights as you go with
detailed reporting of conversion rates
profit margins and beyond so if you've
got a business online you need to be on
shopify it's the best it's so user
friendly we love it if you go to
shopify.com
hey babe all lowercase okay no uppercase
[ __ ] all lowercase shopify.com hey
babe for a free 14-day trial and get
full access to shopify's entire suite of
features you can you're going to get a
sorry
what i need you to do right now is go to
shopify.com hey babe all lowercase and
you're going to get a free 14-day trial
that's what it's going to do 14 free
days of shopify i mean what else do you
want it's amazing shopify.com hey babe
grow your business shopify today go to
shopify.com hey babe right now because
growing up we know we learned from
movies and popular culture that the guy
that lives on the graveyard is a little
iffy he's a little right now there's a
he what's he doing over there the grave
digger yeah he's suspect but i will tell
you i bet you i bet you it is one of the
it's a very peaceful job you're outside
and usually cemeteries for the most part
are
pretty beautiful well and it's also if
you can get past go school spirits and
things the movie if you can get past
that yeah the cemetery is a very safe
place i mean everybody's dead but when
you hear a noise at night but if you can
get past go schools and all that yeah
and and and just say that's from the
movies right right that's wes craven
made that up i picture that guy walking
around like a lantern
you know what i mean
like i'm sure it's like not what we
think it is right he probably has
internet right yeah he's probably a very
very normal guy what about when they
used to bury people back in the day they
would have to bury you with the bell
with there was bells at the grave so
just in case you were buried alive you
could ring this bell from the coffin
back i'm alive that's happened you know
what that's happened to people in my
entire life i have never heard mention
of anything that you just said google
grave bells google get ready to get your
bells blown off safety coffin no way
safety coffin employed a bell as a
signaling device for anybody buried
alive this happened a lot in history sal
you're living in a good time what
happened to just making sure they were
dead first
i know you know what like why run the
risk
they should have done i would have done
that at least everybody just to make
sure
just to make sure every single person i
buried if i was the coroner back then
i'd give them one bullet to the head i
should ride the head once just to be
sure you have tons of money on bills
yeah so or now to the head if you want
to if you if you're if it's wartime and
you need the bullets then we'll do
mallet to the head yeah it's peacetime
we can use a bullet it's not what you
have to make sure for me i would just be
like i would badger them a lot like wake
up are you alive are you alive wake up
are you here we go the subject
oh yeah tickle their armpits that's what
i do too tickle them
tickle their feet if you're not if
you're gunned down get yourself a
feather yeah that's right you're peace
you're a peaceful guy yeah the fall of
the house of usher which was has nothing
to do with her oh
the fall of the house of urcher and the
cask of amentillado
edgar allen poe wrote the premature
burial which was published in 1844 which
encounters a supposedly genuine case of
premature burial as well as detailing a
narrator uh internment while still alive
wow because basically what would we
obviously the science was different so
maybe there was times where they buried
someone and then at certain point they'd
just go
and like pop up like you know how they
do that in the movies yeah oh any movie
where i see someone very loud i'm
claustrophobic
yeah it's it's literally i have like
nightmares of that kind of thing right
it's bad news bad news yeah do you get
claustrophobic on like a plane and stuff
yeah i just gotta breathe and we've got
it this week i had to go to toronto and
i flew on porter airlines
by the way porter airlines no good pull
yourself together jesus porter makes
spirit look like
air force one i got a new name for them
port-a-potty airlines yeah i mean no
disrespect i know but but the plane
the plane was like
this isn't it was like folding chairs it
was disgusting it was they had and they
had the they have the
the gall the unmitigated goal
to break it into economy premium and
premium plus
so i go i get booked by the production
because i had to go up to the film uh i
don't know if i mentioned this i'm uh
can you say it they didn't tell me not
to i have a little guest role
very little it's like five lines or
whatever on what we do in the shadows
great show which is one i think it's the
funniest show on television one of my
funniest shows i love it yeah i love it
they had no idea i was a fan it takes
place in the universe of the show on
staten island so by by nature of that
fact i i'm playing myself on the show
for a short stint amazing
uh it was dream come true i went up to
toronto film they booked me on porter
airlines
go with the flow uh i went on i realized
that it was an economy seat and they had
premium premium applause let me just
look at how much it is to upgrade
how much do you think it was to upgrade
from economy
to premium
okay economy to premium i would argue
was a hundred and forty dollars
seventeen dollars
seventeen dollars okay that was the
difference that was the difference for
every seat so if you wanted to go from
economy to anything in the premium rose
it was 17 17. how much to get to premium
plus
i mean now knowing this information 23
22 22 premium plus was five dollars more
than premium and they were 17 dollars
more than economy i took the premium
plus wow cause let me get premium plus
well this podcast is doing well the
first row was open i paid 22 bucks on my
credit i switched my seat i get there i
go to sit in seat 1a
okay
and it's only see one and one b and
that's and i go to sit down and my hips
don't lie
and they had to be squeezed into the
seat to the point where the right side
of the seat on my hip was actually
painful
wow
the stewardess was in the fold-out seat
three feet right in front of my face
she's right here on the fold-out seat
and i i sit and i go
this can't be right like i i'm not that
big no you know
and the chairs were this thing they were
like full dodgers and i go excuse me i
go uh
how am i not fitting in this chair is
premium plus or whatever right and she
goes oh yeah so since it's the first row
they have the tables that you eat on in
the middle and it juts out like
no joke like four inches into the seat
and you pull it out and she goes she
goes actually the seats you're in the
premium plus are the
tightest seats on the plane
she tells me that the tightest
if you want you can go back and sit in
one of the other rows so is that what
you did yeah and i and i paid for the
upgrade and went back and talked about
that so you so you should get your money
back port-a-potty
i'll open up an investigation get the 22
back i'd hire a lawyer on the way home
did they start i didn't want to make the
same mistake no food what profit you got
you have a pretzel a
mini pretzel bag a mini almond bag or a
mini cookie cookie what'd you go with
going
i went with almonds interesting coming
home i did do a shortbread cookie you
did you have to yeah what's the flight
new york to toronto not long 75 minutes
it's like you're up you're down 80
minutes yeah right which is why i was
like fine it is what it is but then
coming back i was like i'm not going to
make that mistake again so they had me
in row 10 but there was people they
didn't separate people for covert which
i didn't know that i thought you had to
do that no no no airlines have been
packing them in so so so i go i'm not
gonna sit up there again i'm not gonna
make that mistake so i just take the
seat they assigned me i sat down a woman
sits right next to me the row it's a
small plane so it's two and two
it's the same exact tight seat minus
that thing but it's still like this and
then this woman sits next to me so we're
just sitting there like this and i
started to get a claustrophobic attack i
haven't had one in so long and i i
started to like start to sweat and i
feel like i couldn't breathe
and like i swear to god and they the
plane was so hot and the things weren't
working oh my god and i just was like i
started to breathe really heavy and i
started to like almost hyperventilate
and a woman was walking by and the front
row was open
i didn't take it and so she went by and
i go excuse me i go i don't want to i
just want to get on a good side right so
i just was like
i i was so like i was like when is
convenient for you yeah i like talk very
softly i said hi i hope you have a good
day when is convenient for you i was
wondering if uh at any point i could
move to those empty seats there uh
because so it would sacrifice so me and
her could be more comfortable i included
the lady yeah smart and then and she
said uh there's still more people coming
on the plane ah and then i waited like
10 minutes and they closed the door and
then she walked by again i said
yeah and uh she said god go do it and i
did it so then i sat in my with my hips
squashed again alone though alone but
and the lady when i get up she goes
don't worry i'm not taking offense to
this
you shouldn't you shouldn't never like i
don't know
yeah like she thought i was just like
like like i don't know i guess she maybe
she was making a joke no i know i mean
yeah well if she's canadian but she
wasn't making a joke like kind of
see that's the thing with some of these
flights
is like
i kind of think airline travel is going
to be one of those things where
200 years from now they're gonna look
back like remember when people used to
pack in the tubes and do that and fly
could you imagine like like how like it
was very normal to someone from the
1870s to be like oh it's going to take
me six years
to get to pennsylvania right new york is
just going to take
many of us will die we're doing spring
break down south 1894. right we're
leaving now we'll leave it now it's
1880. it's 1881 and half our family's
gonna die of tide forward fever right
and but that's just what it is we're
going on vacation why do you think were
you alive when you could smoke on a
plane that was wild no but i i i have
been on planes and i have ash trays
still yeah you know which is nuts so i
think that airline travel it's got it
has to get better because airline travel
is one of those things that hasn't
really changed much
i mean yes you have more features now
you have a tv you have a first-class
experience all that but i'm talking
about the economy yeah coach seat
experience hasn't changed much besides
you get tv you might get a tv you might
get tv yeah no it's yours they got us by
the ball someone has to rise up against
these people airline travels you know by
the way by the way
but i will tell you this i was looking
up airline tickets for my fort
lauderdale and west palm beach shows
yeah 57
round trip what 57
the highest cost was like 81
on every across every airline to florida
round trip wow round trip it was 28 each
way oh my god i guess they're just
losing so much that well and you know
what's happening now with the airlines
is they're saying like do not fly after
like december something they said do not
do not um
fly because this strike the the um it's
not about the the
the flight the pilots and the flight
attendants the flight control people in
the tower which you can't easily replace
them like that like you have to go to
school for that yeah shout out to vaughn
institute yeah that's one of the schools
that does that um
they are going on strike allegedly after
december and it was going to be like
massive already southwest airlines and
spirit airlines canceled southwest
airlines cancelled 1500 flights last
year in anticipation of this no they had
a walker they had a worker walk out
something no way stop working really
yeah that it's going to be it's like a
big mike they want but they want better
working conditions and paying what they
don't want better work this is better
pay and they don't want the vaccine
mandate that's the what they don't want
they don't want that
so it's about vaccination stuff mostly
and also other stuff but that but
they're saying it's going to be like you
will be stranded so we have to mentally
prepare to be stranded in these places
and just we'll have to should we just
get a bus an rv should we just drive an
rv so we were talking about that like at
least in texas maybe we just drive and
in ohio we just drive should we get a
bus missouri we'll do two two different
ones yeah wouldn't want to do it i don't
know if a bus might be a lot what about
an rv
let's talk this out this will be fun i
want to talk to
you want to talk about we should look at
what the drive times are at the very
least at the very least we don't want to
drive ourselves because i was i talked
about this already with our peeps okay
and i was like oh these are close like
enough to maybe to drive because by the
time you know how it goes by the time
it's a three-hour drive by the time you
get to an airport early because that
takes longer yeah but i was figuring you
would have equipment
and so even if we got an suv and if we
had any friends with us anyone else i
know he'd fit so i would like maybe
we'll get a sprinter get a sprinter yeah
something like that let's get a sprinter
and then let's uh we can sing the wheels
on the bus we'll do that and then in the
show in san antonio we got to go to the
alamo
oh god we gotta be there
um you been
oh yeah it's funny right oh yeah cause
not like on tv
it looks like it's like in the desert or
something no but then it's like
literally a cross street from a
starbucks it's a course tree from a day
from a ripley's believe it or not yeah
there's a rip please believe it or not
first time i started i was like wow this
is just the animal in the middle of the
city in the middle of the city um i um i
yeah so i think i think airline travel
is going to be one of those things that
it's it's getting bad because amtrak too
the trains are going to go on strike two
there's gonna be no way to get to
transport yourself unless uh unless
you're in a car
so that's what i'm gonna do or we could
jog unicycle
what are you doing give me a unicycle
no but you know what i saw you could do
a unicycle i feel like you would do a
unicycle i could see you rolling up with
a unicycle and i wouldn't blink
i'll try to get off the unit how do you
get off the like those big wheels you
know like in the circus those big wheels
how do you get off it it's a maneuver it
certainly is a maneuver yeah the
unicycle when was it uh penny after
creation of the first penny far thing
bicycles are introduced by the public by
eugene meyer of paris oh so the bicycle
was only invented in 1870 i thought it
would be way before that oh my god way
before so everybody was just walking
everywhere before that
i guess you just had roller skating
what do they have i feel like the
unicycle came before the bicycle what
came first the bicycle or the roller
skate
is it a bicycle in a unicycle
wasn't a bicycle or a unicycle
what's the deal
interesting i never thought about wow
roller skating was invented in 1735
this next one is just for couples and
love see that's these new wheeled shoes
at a party in london and promptly crash
into a mirror
that's what it says
that's why mom's always imagining the
guy that walked into the body's like i
put [ __ ] wheels on my juice check
this out he just goes right out the
window
that's why moms always insist their kids
wear helmets while learning how to skate
monsieur petaler bed patented the roller
skate in 1819.
shout out monsieur
um
that's interesting uh so
i would like to try a unicycle i'm gonna
put that on my to do's of 2022. okay no
i should do 22.
then you got to buy one can you rent it
let's rent the unicycle in texas or st
louis what else are we going to do we
want to rent the unicycle you want to
rent a unicycle or columbus or
cincinnati maybe we could get someone to
teach us
i wonder if you become proficient in it
if it's like the funnest thing ever can
somebody email heybaypod gmail.com and
if you're in one of those cities can you
please we'd like to do a unicycle we
will or if you have a unicycle i'll tell
you what though i don't think i'm going
to like you in a cycle i'll tell you why
i need something to do with my hands
i feel but i can't just be on the
unicycle my hands out my side speeding
through the town well if you mash the
bait on the unicycle okay then that
gives you something there you go
um this is a well-kept secret unicycling
is not difficult sally babes they don't
tell us you don't even have to try hard
you can be hard but you don't even have
to try hard just put in the time
ah your body will then learn by itself
once you are good at it riding unicycle
is just as easy as riding a bike also
called a unicycle with training wheel or
cycle for the disabled by some
unicyclists
oh i could put training wheels on a
unicycle i don't even think i can get on
a disabled person's unicycle
with the training wheels i couldn't wait
why would it
why would they make it
i guess that's how you learn did you
learn how to ride a bike with training
wheels i did oh yeah yeah yeah clove
lakes park babe clove lakes that's where
i learned what do you like better clove
lakes or silver lake clove lake is uh
club lakes is way way bigger
yeah silver lake is great yeah but clove
is definitely a better park close the
big one i like that we get very inside
inside baseball on staten island
specifically on this podcast pretty much
weekly now yeah shout out shout out
pasta vino shout out i've been talking
them up
there they're a restaurant on staten
island that is actually superb and i
have to give them a shout out they don't
deliver you got to go there unbelievable
there's no delivering no you got to go
there you got to sit down but the place
is beautiful too so right it's an
awesome place i'm going to go to pasta
vino um i am sorry for getting so inside
staten island i know like our fam we
have a lot of fans in the uk yeah you
know we have a lot of fans in the uk a
lot and australia should we go to the uk
in 2022 i
i think 100 100 would come to the uk 100
100 i started talks already
you did yes
uh
i was asked if i wanted to go to the uk
and i said 100 that was the talks
i i i would like to go yeah because i we
tore out there with the guys it's been a
while and i've never toured out their
solo and they are awesome out there man
can you just i love the uk can you go to
the uk now and tour
can you go there good question i don't
know if you could even go i don't know i
know louis j gomez just went to the uk
yeah but he doesn't really abide by any
rules he doesn't care yeah i mean if
you're gonna have to get a million cove
i mean well we'll see
body snatching pimp has pulled up body
snatching it's a removal of corpses from
burial sites a common purpose of
bodybuilding that's horrible especially
in the 19th century was to sell the
corpses for dissection or anatomy
lectures in medical school so really
body snatching is misunderstood yeah
because it's like you're snatching my
body like how would i feel about this
like let's say it's the 1800s you snatch
my grandma's body but you're dissecting
her body to make it medical strides yeah
so it's like
listen
yeah but how about where does his
medical school
think the body's coming from the guy
that shows up at the door scratching
himself begging for money real quick
yeah it's like like they're like oh this
sounds good this is on the up-and-up but
how else how else did they get bodies
unless they were snatching them
i don't know how could you how could you
what am i gonna die because i donate my
body
you know what i heard if you have donate
your organs on the back of your life how
are you gonna say yeah that they they
will now try to revive you that's crazy
i'm telling you that has to be a foul
it's not a foul
don't gotta be a foul i'm telling you
think about that that's insane
malpractice it is you go to jail i don't
know what what is the what is the person
in the hospital or the emt on the scene
or whatever it is what are they gaining
i don't know
i don't know i dude i have no idea i was
just told this
by a
can you put that up but is it true that
let's take this ride with pimp
is it true to that
is it true that how do you want to work
is it true that once a cheater always a
cheater
that's the person that goes up wait
let's read
is it true that the first one is is it
true that once cheetah oh is it cheater
second is it true that love never dies
third is it true that song
four is it true that in spanish
oh
there's more after that is it true that
song says this is it true that in
spanish
okay so the rest of them aren't as good
is it true that japanese are you true
that channel oh so type in that type in
japanese and let's see what comes in is
it's true that japanese
is it true that japanese police won't
chase you oh is it true that japanese
don't buy american products that's
painful is it true that japan
can you google that can you click on
that what comes up
please chase you yeah
what is this about
japanese
here go go up to the top
they answered it on quora right there
yeah
is it
so everybody else has done a good job of
answering why
the deal gives away um i can't see that
right now the club has very strict rules
what is going on
that they won't chase you because you
know police if you can get away if you
want to commit a crime right now and you
want to get away with it a good thing to
do actually is invest try to get into a
high speed chase through a residential
neighborhood yeah yes you might tell
innocent people but
police typically will stop
the chase because they don't want you to
hurt any hurt anybody or or you know
damaged property but they'll let you get
away but as soon as you start to flee
and then you get caught into that you're
subject to more time in prison i think
right but it's a real split-second
decision you got to make right there it
is but my point is is is is is if you're
going to go to jail anyway if it's going
to be like you're so screwed because you
have you know 50 pounds of heroin in
your backseat you're listening listen up
listen and just race through a
residential race through the residential
area because at least you have that
small chance of hope where i can get
away with this and then i'll ditch the
heroine right right you know now i
actually sit at home and watch all the
best speed chases high-speed chases on
youtube oh that's a whole lot oh
god
what is this that he switched
runs through cars
wait what is this guy doing this video
is labeled the real-life grand theft
auto
why did he do that
why did she get out of the car with her
kid in the car wait what just happened
there's a child inside
right now there's a child inside that
and the mother just jumped out and then
why would you jump out of the car with
your child inside wait why didn't she
back up when he blocked her and ran to
her car let's have a gun or something
yeah but still i'll get i'm not leaving
my kid because it goes pretty fast
oh my god and there's a child in the car
right now there's a child in the car
right now god speeding and it looks like
a wet road yeah what happens holy and
it's 21 degrees icy conditions
it's always fun to jump through these
videos is this like a a parent taking
stealing their own child or is this like
literally no this is a guy in the loose
just running from the cops
no this is the same chase
oh my god he just throws that woman out
of the car
what the hell why does he keep so he
left the kid in the other car but he
went like a hundred the kiddo
holy [ __ ] what is no one choosing him
there's no one cheating it's not even
police anywhere near it he sees the
helicopter and there is cops chasing him
well where are they you see they come to
frame again but what does he think
switching a car
while the helicopter films him this is
pretty going to do he's on meth you're
also driving in pure white snow where
you're just any other color just
sticking out oh my god oh my god he's
approaching interesting oh my god oh my
god oh
now it's gonna get out again he tries to
get out again look at this guy oh my god
oh my god this is wild dude this is
literally grand theft auto it's
literally grand theft auto bro take the
coat off it's slowing you down crack
he's wearing a coat like joey from
blossom right now take it off
where is he going dude he has to this
guy fully has to be on crack i've never
seen this video and this is fascinating
i could watch this all day where are the
police they're not giving chase that's
why i watch at home there's one that was
40 minutes long this guy went on oh this
guy just just fell on ice and his coat
came off when he slipped on the ice yeah
no well now he's going to die
oh look it must be freezing out because
you can see his breath well look it says
21 degrees oh my god what is he doing i
gotta be honest with you this is like a
new sport oh my god crossfit he couldn't
jump defense he couldn't jump the fence
i thought he did crosstalk
what are you doing now he's done get on
the floor stupid
oh you're dunsky you are done
let's see if they give him a
these cops look out of shape
like that was that was legit grand theft
auto oh yeah legit he he walked up to
cars that were at lights and ripped the
people out five times this is my new
favorite thing on youtube i also watch
uh for some reason whenever anyone even
near famous gets arrested
they publish the body camera footage the
police department monetizes the body
camera footage no really i watched a
very famous youtuber he randomly went
out of his house on coke and punched a
woman walking down the street right in
the face and then i watched him get
arrested for an hour
that's entertainment like it was a lot
happening live no they edited it and
dropped it but you don't see him punch
the woman no but you see what he did
right
it's crazy this is now entertainment wow
interesting interesting interesting well
you know well hopefully we get arrested
and then we get our footage let's go
you're at a zoo i was thinking this from
before
i don't know how i can't figure out if
you have big eyes or small eyes
what do you mean like big like like like
the ovalness of them i just don't know
if your big eyes are small eyes
you were your glasses down
leaning forward in all seriousness
saying that to me you just looked you
look like like a nine-year-old man to me
right now like
puerto rican
man i can't take you serious
what what do you mean
i open them big
okay no let me seem small
let me see him regular
oh small would be like
but what do you mean like how much the
lids open or the balls themselves
i would say you have big
balls
and a small
oval shaped lid so the answer would be
you have medium eyes
give me an example of somebody with big
eyes so i understand and small eyes
somebody with big eyes stay away from
anything racist please okay
well but if it doesn't matter what race
they are if they have big eyes they have
big eyes correct
big eyes would be steve buscemi okay
well that's a okay he's known for that
so you you couldn't tell if i had his
eyes
my it's the glasses
okay these are things but but
you have very nice eyes thanks i don't
really don't know anyone in big big eyes
who's got small eyes
you gotta oh that's when they say like
beady eyes yeah bdi who's got swords
type in small eyes see who comes up well
celebrities these are just beautiful
women that i will never even look at
their eyes yeah now one of these people
looks like this put big eye celebrities
in
big-eyed celebrities uh maybe um thurman
thurman's got big eyes i love him
i love that
maya rudolph not her um
mila kunis mila kunis shout out john
cusack but is she a big eyes she's just
doing uh that thing with that with the
uh that's a sex eye when you make a sex
eye it's a small eye you know like like
when when you're having sex you're like
that's sexy because you're gonna go like
this
that sounds sexy
yeah
um you know who's sexy you know who's
you know who's
who's a sexy guy who like i'm talking
about a guy i'd legitimately
like i'm talking about legitimately go
down on him nope
like that tom brady
you're right and you know what he
deserves it because he's a champion he
is over and over and over he won the
super bowl shout out to him win the
super bowl this year yeah you know 43
years old old sky nfl yeah they won it
in tampa
which is the first time they've ever
done teams one in their home city the
tampa bay buccaneers as my mom is
calling the tampa bay buckaroos
buckaroos and she would say that like
like confidently like on the tampa bay
buckaroos there's not many people
who could hope
that they put that they have the career
of tom brady there's only a couple only
couple nib remits if i didn't mention
patreon home shout out him for coming in
he's one second place he's a big andrew
santino comedy fan
what he is patrick mahomes is a big
andrew santino comedy fan he goes
through shows every time he performs in
dallas we'll be in dallas too in
december december 26th yeah we'll be in
dallas that's where my homes is from and
we'll also be in missouri december 29th
yeah that's right god bless everybody go
tickets are on the side sugarland
sugarland i think that's dallas then
also grand prairie is really grand
prairie prairie and then grand prairie
sugarland san antonio grand prairie san
antonio sugarland st louis columbus
cincinnati december 26 to the 31st
columbus get in there get in there
columbus we're gonna ride unicycles yeah
we're gonna ride unicycles cincinnati
for new year's eve and then yes stand up
comedy baby december 30th columbus uh
ohio which was recently named indigenous
people ohio
i love columbus shout out columbus is
asleep for town columbus is they got
some cool stuff in clubs there's a cool
downtown area there i love columbus the
last time me and you went to columbus we
ate at a real southern comfort place yes
and then we went to an insane little
trinket shop toy store toy bought my
daughter a red leather jacket yes yes
yes you do remember columbus glove
columbus yeah we'll be back again yes
the owner of one of the comedy clubs i
forgot which one in columbus uh told me
out of bob evans that he had herpes this
has been happening
[Music]
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey i
don't want